the best offense dane dunning has seen
in his young major league careers not
wasting any time ready to go again
line shot to first senatorial pulls that
one out of the air and a one two three
go the minnesota twins here in the first
inning
so eloy jimenez with two down leads
major league baseball
in damage right side he does it again
sox lead one nothing real early tonight
in game two
lloyd jimenez is really starting to heat
it up steve take us through what's
happening here
uh yeah that's about it they've cut the
strap off the mask
yeah they're trying to figure out a way
to stick it to his face
does anybody have macgyver's number so
they're gonna
re-strap the mask for will little yeah i
think that's one thing that
umpires who up behind the plate really
want i want to make sure that mask is
going to stay
in the proper spot because he's probably
going to get hit
upstairs strike three basketball cut him
down one gone
two on and here is yo yo
really good fastball well the white sox
have left four men on
again here tonight they've got a
one-nothing lead and we go to the third
and then here's byron buxton starting
the twins third
to center field and deep robert going
back
leaping and he does not make the play
and crashes into the fence
buxton who nearly had an inside the park
home run last night
will have one tonight and the game is
tied
byron buxton off the center field fence
his ninth home run of the year and it's
one apiece
i was saying get on base to provide a
spark but that's about his biggest spark
as you can provide right there
he wasn't even running as fast as he
could
until he hit second base and then all of
a sudden that elite speed
kicked in but then to put it back in
gear the helmet came flying off before
third came home and scored very easily
infield's still in this becomes one of
the bigger in bats
james mccann in the air right center and
that plugs the alleyway
just short of the warning track sox
retake the lead james into second rbi
double
the james gang celebrating 2-1 two in
scoring position now for luis roberts
robert up the origin drawn in in field
that's a shame two run single louise
robert 4-1
socks that's 30 driven in and that time
he got one down in the zone and took
it by a diving blankenhorn
this one called a pass ball and the
ground ball to madrigal will
result in an out but he'll get the twins
a run thanks to
buxton's ability to advance abreu at
second mccann at first
three and two to robert and inside with
a fastball got him to chase two down and
that'll bring up angle
and a fly ball center field buxton
routine for him and he puts that away so
nice job by
tyler clifford coming in and retiring
the two batters that he faced they
strand two
be nice if the stocks can score another
run or two this is
not the kind of lead you like even in
the bottom of the six you got two runs
and you get a thunderous offense you're
facing
three two hit in the air left field side
rosario going back still going at the
track at the wall
get the poster ready it's that's the
second change up in the at-bat and the
second one leaves the ballpark
i told you tim on an off-speed pitch and
a breaking ball in the zone
is really tough and if you throw one you
better not go there again
as tim lifts a high fly ball his eighth
home run of the year he's driven in 19
and there is an insurance run another
one-two pitch
strike three called and the inning is
over
career-high tying seventh strikeout for
dane dunning
and the white sox will carry themselves
a 5-2 lead
three balls two strikes uh james mccann
that balls well hit to left field
rosario back at the track at the wall
bring him home james mccann
adds another six to two
sixth home run he's now driven in 14
including a pair tonight
and a four-run lead base miguel cino
and the worst snow could do is make it
6-3
on the ground foster
now that looked a lot like a hockey
goalie coming right back through the
middle
1-2
buxton right side angle
sox win again two in a row against
minnesota
the lead is three in the ao central